journée spéciale pour ces étudiants de
l'estaca aujourd'hui lucas etienne et
plusieurs membres de leur équipe col des
stickers sur leur première voiture de
rallye une grande étape dans leurs
projets automobiles ça fait plaisir
c'est un projet qui sa boutique mine de
rien on commence à voir
l'échéance arrivait donc donc c'est
sympa une nouvelle étape pour ce projet
imaginé pendant le premier confinement
mais 2020 lucas et qui prend forme
depuis la rentrée 2021 aux côtés
d'étienne tous deux novices dans ce
secteur l'objectif de ces deux
passionnés de sport automobile être la
première équipe 100% étudiante à prendre
le départ d'un rallye et à le terminer
on avait vraiment envie de remettre en
avant le sport automobile mais pas sur
le domaine du circuit le circuit c'est
quelque chose que on a l'occasion
d'avoir un petit peu partout et on avait
envie de partir sur rallye puisque
malheureusement le rallye c'est une
discipline qui est peu mis en avant dans
aujourd'hui dans le sport automobile
bien qu' on est des grands champions
comme un sébastien loeb sébastien ogier
aujourd'hui le projet mobilise une
trentaine de personnes de l'école
d'ingénieur il prépare cette voiture
achetée 12000 euros pour la rendre
compétitive comme voiture de base c'est
une 106 s16 donc elle est préparée donc
n 2 même top n2 donc en n2 c'est une
catégorie de rats lyon où on prépare les
voitures mais le but c'est de rester sur
vraiment un petit budget donc elle est
assez préparés andrieu basiquement c'est
à dire on l'intérêt évident et il ya un
arceau
voilà le moteur est juste
reprogrammer un peu mais après tout le
reste ça reste d'origine après plusieurs
mois de travaux et des dizaines d'heures
passées chaque semaine sur la mécanique
le bolide est presque terminée les
sportifs pourront enfin prendre la route
après des mois d'entraînement sur
simulateur la voiture devrait participer
à sa première course début mai au rallye
du coeur de lion dans l'eure donc on a
des sièges qui sont assez spécifique
qu'il faut homologué environ tous les
trois quatre ans pour que cela soit
encore homologué ainsi que les harnais
c'est pareil à une homologation de 3 4
ans ensuite on a ce qui nous permet de
survivre au cas où s'il ya un arbre qui
traversent la route donc les arceaux
c'est à dire que c'est une cage en métal
en acier qui a s'est renforcé à ses
pairs au revoir je peux taper dedans
c'est cesser complètement plein au total
les deux étudiants devraient prendre le
volant sur quatre courses avant la fin
de l'été leur objectif terminer les
courses dans un premier temps et
pourquoi pas viser un top 10 en fin de
saison
[Musique]